[Musik]
erste Arroganz der Engländer der
Brexit eine Kartoffel und ein Manga praktisch
Chanson Oignon ist sehr krass oder
Fahnenflucht Cindy sehr Thema Werbung Knutson
für das Handwerk folgt
[Musik]
hallo ich mache gerade ein paar Geschäfte
da nach dem Brexit einige Produkte
werden  werden sehr teuer und sehr selten
in Großbritannien okay und ich habe einige hier
vielleicht interessiert es dich es ist für deinen
Big Ben du wirst rot es ist ziemlich
lustig du kennst den Mann auf der Straße große Kiste
wenn ich nicht verrückt bin willst du es nur  hilfe
bananen zum beispiel werden sehr
teuer wenn es zu gesund ist kann man sie
auch frittieren so kann ich
es euch erklären ist das irgendwie ja als eine art
vegetarische wurst auch das wird
in britannien nach dem brexit rar und teuer
toilettenpapier  Nehmt an, ihr werdet in
einer sehr beschissenen Situation sein. Ich verstehe nicht, dass
ich eine Socke benutzen werde. Das ist ein sogenannter
Zwerg von Shlomo. Hmm, kannst du sagen, es
gab eine Milch, alle Shimer
Sie können Schaum
auf dem Bier machen  ja wie ein Cappuccino ja
aber genau dieser Chino der weiß ich weiß
niemand weiß mach wie ich weiß ich bin aus
Deutschland wir wissen alles
Marcel gute Autos darum geht es
darum
[Musik]
mein Plan
einer was ist am besten
mr.  Jung, oh nein, ich mag jünger, jetzt liege ich
auf dem Boden, er ist die einzige Person, die ich kenne
, die mich denken lässt, ich habe kein
großes Problem, was kann die EU
tun, damit Sie
nichts bleiben, damit Sie wollen, dass Großbritannien die
U verlässt?  ende oktober gibt es eine
chance dich von einem anderen tag zu überzeugen
und welchen sinn hätte ein weiterer
tag früher zu gehen was willst du dass
wir gehen ich will dass du so schnell wie
möglich gehst du hast die brexit party gegründet um das zu
zeigen  du bist verantwortlich für den brexit
dass du verantwortlich bist also wie wird
deine party nach dem brexit
bankrott party heißen nein noch
brexit party deutsch ich liebe deine autos ich
liebe deine küchen aber du wirst
unsere tollen küchen nicht mehr bekommen  Sie werden
so teuer sein, dass wir vielleicht sogar aufhören,
machen Sie Ihren Koch schreckliches Zeug in ihren
Küchen. Ich bin Sie und Ihre Würste, Sie
können nicht darüber reden, was
mit unseren Würsten los ist
nach dem Brexit  Ja,
ich komme aus Deutschland und verkaufe einige
Produkte, die nach dem Brexit teuer sein werden, also wird
dies für
immer teuer werden. Sie wollen das oder
Sie denken, Sie haben Ihr Land bereits genug [ __ ]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
guten Tag in förderlich  und eine buddhistische
Jota-Show YouTube kann gegen sie helfen, die bisher am
wenigsten entwickelt und darüber sind